starting off this hours Jacob in
Columbia South Carolina welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Jacob hey thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up um so I just got eligible
I'm in my fourth year of school I'm
graduating in May and I have zero
student loan debt good but I have racked
up about 2,700 in credit card debt
um and I just finished the application
for student loans and I've already paid
off everything for school but they're
letting me take seven thousand in loans
I'm able to accept that as of yesterday
it's five thousand subsidized the other
none subsidized but should I take those
loans no and pay off my credit card
portion of it okay no you know your
student loans pay off credit card debt
to start with it's morally wrong it's
morally wrong to borrow money on the
taxpayers back to go to school and use
it to pay your bills you say no you're
supposed to do that but aside from that
no I mean it's 2,700 bucks what's your
degree in I knew what finance finance
good okay and so um your that's what's
causing the problem you're overanalyzing
this mathematically aren't you okay it's
only $2,700 you're gonna get a nice job
in May right hopefully so yeah nothing
and just pay you 2,700 off man don't
don't monkey around with trying to beat
the system
for a couple of points of interest for
just a few months you're gonna be
debt-free by September okay hopefully so
yeah cut up cut up the card um good so
yeah I mean that right if you run the
math out you're comparing the the
interest rate annually on the credit
card to the interest rate annually on
the student loan data weren't you yeah
yeah and so you're trying to run
arbitrage on it what we're taught when
we do when we get finance degrees I've
got one two and so but the problem is
there's two things when you run it out
what I had to learn to do in personal
finance
especially was when you run out the math
that actually occurs here ok so let's
say that you did this and you still paid
off the twenty seven hundred dollars of
student loan debt only okay by September
and so you have borrowed money
effectively from now until September
let's call it six months okay what is
the student loan interest rate the loan
interest rate five percent okay and what
is the credit card interest rate between
sixteen and twenty six percent okay
let's call it twenty four round numbers
okay so we have a 15 percent spread oh
but wait we only have six months right
okay so we have a seven point seven five
spread so let's put $2,700 0.075 it's a
two hundred dollar discussion we're
having okay you see that that's the
whole savings after all this gyration
with the arbitrage so the problem with
what the way you and I are taught in
academia and you're going to have to
avoid this in your personal finances is
that we are taught these theoretical
things that happen in a vacuum like this
like that like that interest rate
savings is pure it's not pure to start
with because you're going to have costs
are going to postage you have envelopes
you have your time invested you have all
those other things and so the arbitrage
is not pure you're going to end up
making enough to buy fast food dinner
one night by the time this all clears on
all this generation because you know it
because you get caught up in the gross
interest rates rather than the nominal
actual savings net net net of all
expenses including opportunity cost on
your time to screw with this not to
mention the fact that you shouldn't
borrow student loans to pay off credit
card debt but that's a side issue and
once I wanted to go back and cover the
other part because sometimes we do
things with our intellect that mental
gymnastics that actually tricks us into
a bad decision and that's what I was
trying to avoid you're freaky to help
you to avoid doing in the future